bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de check up votre magazine santé
bien-être
au sommaire de cette édition nous
évoquons la campagne de recrutement du
département des médecins pour les
centres de pin sont recherchés nous
parlerons également trisomie 21 un
accueil a ouvert ses portes à montigny
le bretonneux
mais tout d'abord place au premier sujet
c'est devenu un rendez vous régulier
chaque mois nous partons en immersion
dans l'un des services de l'hôpital
privé de l'ouest parisien de trappes
cette fois ci nous avons suivi le
quotidien du service des urgences et le
diwan pour les images
il est 8h les patients affluent déjà au
service des urgences la salle d'attentes
se remplit peu à peu et les
consultations ses succès qu'est ce qui
est arrivé à la main tu t'es quoi le
parcours démarre ici
passage obligé chez l'infirmier
d'accueil et d'orientation
ce jour là c'était millien qui s'en
charge il reçoit tous les patients sans
exception avant de les orienter vers les
médecins c'est moi qui vais décider de
prioriser ou pas selon selon la
pathologie ce dont surtout critère c'est
l'urgence
voilà qui vont passer plus ou moins tôt
par rapport au reste de la file
l'urgence médicale et la douleur sont
les deux éléments deux priorités
principaux après s'être occupé des
premiers soins et des constantes telles
que la prise de température
emilien rassure ses passions t'as pas
rater ton copain je me tiens ça deux
mange met une bande ces patients vont
ensuite retourné dans la salle d'attenté
avant d'être prise en charge de l'autre
côté par les médecins et infirmières
urgentistes
bonjour si lecteurs et gars je vais
m'occuper de vous aujourd'hui
comment ça va christophe et médecins ici
à trappes depuis cinq ans ce matin il
commence sa journée par un tour en unité
d'hospitalisation de courte durée une
petite unité d'urgence où les patients y
reste jusqu'à 48 heures grand maximum
salut écoutait appel parce que j'ai vu
un jeune homme d'une vingtaine d'années
là ce matin qu'on a regardé au secteur
port pour une suspicion de la pp ici les
patients sont soit en attente d'un
spécialiste pour les hospitalisés soit
en attente de résultats complémentaires
ce matin une appendicite et suspectés
chez l'un des patients qui est le
gastroentérologue de garde
si le diagnostic est confirmé le patient
sera transférée au bloc opératoire dans
la journée pour deux patients ce matin
dans cette unité
christophe qui a passé du temps tandis
qu'un peu plus loin d'autres arrivées ce
matin en urgence attendent toujours
parce que tant qu'on est ici on n'est
pas là bas donc tout le temps qu'on
passe ici on passe du temps de ses des
patients qui ont déjà pris du temps ici
initialement parfois quand ils arrivent
ici c'est qu'ils ont été vus dans deux
ou trois fois réveillée deux ou trois
fois donc nous a pris au moins une heure
de temps médical hier ou dans la nuit
et là ils reprennent encore du temps
médical c'est dépassé
chronophage mais c'est nécessaire et
donc ça ça ralentit le flux d urgence et
les patients comprennent pas pourquoi
est ce qu'ils sont 10 et que ça traîne
les heures passent là files d'attentes
s'allongent à l'hôpital privé de l'ouest
parisien de trappes en moyenne 155
patients transitent chaque jour aux
urgences entre l'entrée et la sortie
le délai est de trois heures 30 environ
bonjour aux médias le marathon commence
pour christophe avec deux autres
collègues c'est ici dans chacun de ses
six box qu'il reçoit les patients de
l'aj auxerre
ça va permettre de résorber le thème
parce que vous avez un oedème là ça qui
nous fait mal hein donc je pense que
votre articulations un petit peu gonflé
on va la faire dégonfler comme ça en
fait de la médecine ont fait tous les
bobos ont fait toutes les grosses
fractures ont réduit des luxations on
suture de grosses plaies on va faire
parfois même un pink sheets
inesthétiques
on fait de la médecine de ville bien
évidemment on fait de la grosse
pathologie médicale avec des
défaillances cardiaques pulmonaires
c'était mal poumon trois mois un cadre
non d'accord sa première fois que tu as
mal comme ça t'as jamais dans la région
de nombreux médecins généralistes parti
à la retraite ne sont pas remplacés pour
la demande actuelle ils sont aujourd'hui
trop peu
alors les patients se tournent vers le
service des urgences pour une prise en
charge rapide c'est une hypotension
effectivement lancé la tension qui chute
d'un malaise vagal simplement parce
qu'elle a eu très mal
c'est ça son souci ce qui fait le gros
de notre de notre activité
c'est certainement pas les arrêts
cardiaques ça c'est clair comme vous
avez pu le constater il ya beaucoup de
petites médecine entre guillemets ce
qu'on appelle de la petite médecine des
des rhumes des choses comme ça qui
viennent vous voulez ralentir notre
notre
progression mais on voit tout on est
amené à tout voir de les regarder là
haut vous ouvrez la bouche vous tirez à
langueux guy à
j'entends rien alors vous explique votre
problème
c'est une infection dit si c'est pas une
infection d'art hockey par essence et
les médecins ne peuvent refuser personne
tout passion qui se présentent aux
urgences ce doit être vue par un médecin
sauf si la pathologie ne répond pas de
leurs compétences telles que la
pédiatrie la gynécologie
vous n'aurez pas la prétention d'avoir
plus de compétences disons que mon champ
d'action est plus large
mais mes compétences sont limitées
malgré tout il ya des choses pour
lesquelles je n'aurais pas le niveau d
expertise nécessaire
le médecin urgentiste travaille donc en
étroite collaboration avec les autres
spécialistes et au sein de son service
avec les infirmières donc je vais vous
faire un bang mais en fait c'est juste
pour éviter que le pouce bouge en fait
voilà donc je vais faire un gantelet je
vais monter jusqu'à là d'accord voilà
arrivés ici il ya plus de dix ans
valérie a noué des liens avec certaines
familles de la région
elle fait partie des doyennes du service
alors c'est pas facile tous les jours il
ya des gens qui sont qui sont agressives
qui sont pas contents mais voilà on
n'est pas là pour juger on est là pour
les écouter on fait au mieux on porte
surtout pas de jugement ça c'est ça
c'est vraiment la règle vous allez
mettre votre moi comme sa fonction
faisait un joli bras de fer
je gagnerai toute façon c'est assez
fatigant en fin de journée en plus voilà
on prend on prend plein de choses on
ressent toute la journée les émotions
des histoires voilà ça c'est vrai que le
soir on part on est on est con et un peu
vide et quand même mais bon voilà c'est
assez génial quoi moi j'adore en tout
cas chaque jour trois médecins et six
infirmières oeuvrent pour le bien-être
de leurs patients
laurence on gère ses équipes avec le
même entrain depuis maintenant trois ans
quand on lui demande ce qui la pousse
chaque jour dans son métier la réponse
est sans équivoque
l'adrénaline il ya toujours deux on ne
sait pas ce qui nous attend et c'est un
peu voilà aller vite et bien faire bien
les choses allaient vite réanimer
quelqu'un pour faire un peu de social ou
console est quelqu'un enfin voilà tout
et on fait tout aux urgences tout et
c'est ça qui est ça qui vous plaît je
pense je vous le disais dans le sommaire
le département des yvelines recrute une
quinzaine de médecins pour ses centres
de pmi pmi pour protection maternelle et
infantile versailles saint quentin en
yvelines ou encore plaisir autant de
secteurs concernés par cette campagne
les médecins recherché de type pédiatres
gynécologues serait amené à faire de la
prévention
avant tout nous écoutons le conseiller
départemental en charge de la famille on
a on n'arrive pas équipés chacun de nos
centres et alors qu'on a une vraie
mission en termes de protection et de
prévention au niveau de l'enfant et de
la mère
les maires qui sont enceintes ont des
possibilités d'avoir des visites dans
les centres de pmi
dans la 2ème de maternelle et pour la
protection infantile les
les médecins avec des affirmations des
tris reçoivent les enfants pour essayer
de détecter les difficultés que pourrait
rencontrer ses enfants son plan de la
santé ou sur le plan éventuellement de
certains certaines déficiences
cognitives par exemple c'est un secteur
intéressant autant pourra s'attendre de
personnes de deux femmes par exemple en
fait médecin qui cherche aussi un cadre
qui est un cadre pas forcément libéral
qui est très astreignant et donc je
pense qu'il vers une certaine
attractivité pour ces métiers au sein du
département
rendez vous sur le site internet ww
point yvelines le point fr dans la
rubrique recrutement pour la liste des
postes à pourvoir
l'envoi des candidatures se fait par
mail emploi compétences @ yvelines point
fr
l'association française pour la
recherche sur la trisomie 21 dispose
depuis quelques mois d'une antenne à
départementale dans les yvelines
elle est basée à montigny le bretonneux
catherine mulato et patrick jacques de
dixmude sont allés à la rencontre des
responsables ici dans le quartier des
prés à montigny le bretonneux
l'association française pour la
recherche sur la trisomie 21 ouvert au
mois d'avril l'antenne départementale
des yvelines
elle reçoit tous ceux qui le souhaitent
le deuxième mercredi de chaque mois de
10 heures à 12 heures pour que les gens
puissent venir poser des questions
s'informer récupérer des vieilles choses
ou des éléments qu'on peut
éventuellement pour les aider les aider
éventuellement sur leur quotidien et bat
aussi pour leur parler que nous on
travaille sur la recherche la frt à
d'ailleurs été créée en 1990 par un
groupe de chercheurs de l'hôpital necker
pour appuyer la recherche sur cette
maladie génétique
l'association collecte des dons pour
soutenir le travail des chercheurs
aujourd'hui 95 % des couples qui
découvrent la trisomie de leurs enfants
pendant la grossesse optent pour
l'avortement
faute selon l'association de traitements
pour améliorer l'état comportementale
des enfants trisomiques la frt au niveau
national rassemble 200 adhérents
ce numéro de check up de touche à sa fin
avant de recruter voici quelques rendez
vous santé à ne pas manquer et on
commence par une exposition à guyancourt
du 15 au 25 juin
la maison de quartier théodore monod
propose des exemples de recherche
française en matière de santé des
travaux sur la nutrition la
traumatologie des handicaps ou encore le
vieillissement des thématiques qui
concernent tout le monde
rendez vous aux heures d'ouverture de la
maison de quartier allez on part du côté
de magny les hameaux le traditionnel
festival heureux mais tes tongs revient
pour sa sixième édition cette année un
peu le santé sera installé au coeur du
village
vous y trouverez notamment un stand de
prévention sur les risques solaires
rendez-vous quartier du buisson du 6 au
13 juillet et une dernière info pour
terminer l'été approche et les grandes
chaleurs aussi il faut rester vigilant
et mobilisé la ville d'elancourt
renouvelle son dispositif prévention
canicule les personnes âgées de plus de
65 ans et les personnes en situation de
handicap peuvent s'inscrire sur le
registre de la ville qui vous aidera en
cas de fortes chaleurs sachez également
qu'une plateforme téléphonique au niveau
national a été mise en place canicule
info service
check up s'est terminé merci de votre
attention je vous donne rendez-vous dans
un mois
d'ici là portez vous bien